oh this is Adam Smith calling from
nobelprize.org the website of the Nobel
Prize in Stockholm well first of all
congratulations on the award of the
Nobel Prize well thank you of course I'm
humbled and thrilled how did the news
come to you I got a telephone call about
ten minutes ago
just before they started the session I
guess so it really couldn't have arrived
any faster the news because the
announcement of gravitational waves was
only made last year putting LIGO
together and getting this result it took
many decades and an awful lot of work
where did that dedication come from I
think a hard question to answer I think
is a personal part you have to be
someone who doesn't need instant
gratification but I think the scientific
goals and the technical challenges were
the two things that equally motivated me
this technical challenges were technical
challenges that were not unbeatable
learn how to do things and had to build
a sensitive enough device it took us 20
years after we built the first version
of my go detector and of course the
science is unbelievable so we're I think
it's not hard to be motivated for 20
years to do the kind of science were
starting to be able to do the precision
of this instrument this point
unbelievable isn't it yes it is the size
of the effect that we measured from the
first event emerging to black hole the
actual size of the signal was about
1,000 the size of a proton what it did
to our apparatus so we were able to
measure a movement or a change of length
of the apparatus by the passage of
gravitational waves to that accuracy and
then measure its form well enough to
decide what a while
that's pretty unbelievable it's a
testament to human ingenuity isn't it to
modern technology science I think this
couldn't have been done fifty years ago
or 20 years ago or 30 years ago it's
taken best modern literature's and
control and engineering will we'll be
welcoming you to Stockholm in December
yeah is great to talk to you in
congratulations okay thank you bye bye
all right